oh when you have a sub it's like a free
day like your teachers gone they're not
gonna know what you did even if they do
they're not gonna know who it was cuz
the sub doesn't know who you are if a
substitute teacher walks into the
classroom like this and kind of you know
ready for a defeat they will be eaten
life this guy looked like really
disheveled his tie and buttons were
always loose and hair flying all the
little hairs we had was like everywhere
I was blatantly not paying attention and
he actually had decided to call me out
in front of the rest of the class and I
was like oh like sorry like this is
really boring and you're not capturing
our attention and he was like okay so
you have a lot to say your big mouth
come to the front of the class and I was
like okay sounds good and he goes if you
talk back to me again I'm gonna give you
a detention slip and I said you can't
give me a detention so if you're a
substitute teacher like I'll just rip it
up and that's it it'll be fine and he
goes oh since you're so confident about
your future why don't you tell me what
else is gonna happen in your future and
I went like this over his head crystal I
said oh let me see you like what's in my
future and he was like you got to get
the [ __ ] out of here go down in school
suspension like he was so mad that I had
pointed out the fact that he was bald I
had everyone in the class laughing when
mr. Sutton my social studies full-time
teacher came back he had asked me what
happened I told him the whole story I
could tell that he was holding back
laughter and he gave me like an extra
detention he's like that's hysterical
but you're you still have detention like
that's awful and I was like okay fair
enough good like I'm glad you think it's
funny but I deserved it so cool so he
was short and he just seemed like very
nerdy we just knew like everybody was
looking at each other we knew something
was gonna happen within about 40 minutes
we didn't think that we were really
gonna have any work to do because
usually when subs come they give you
super easy work and this teacher was
telling us like yeah here's an
assignment that you're gonna do you need
to have it done by the end of class
we're like we're not doing this we were
trying to think of different things we
could come up with and my friends were
like Rihanna you should maybe fake an
asthma attack
I don't know why I thought this was
gonna be a good idea so when we thought
was gonna happen was gonna fake it he's
gonna be like okay a student's sick like
go to the nurse but no he called 9-1-1
i'm like in the corner hiding my face so
he can't see what's going on and like
some of my friends came over to the
corner as well and they're like okay
just act like you're still having a hard
time breathing we'll give you your
inhaler and so i started calming down i
was like oh my god i think it's going
away i think it was a false alarm he's
like no you still need to see the
ambulance when the ambulance came like i
explained to the most like I took my
inhaler and I think I'm just feeling
better it's fine and they like checked
on me and everything they're like
everything's okay
also she mentioned my dad was my
principal in high school as well so none
of this was a smart idea for me to do
and I knew and my dad knows me obviously
I'm his daughter he knew I was not
having an asthma attack oh that was like
a very kind of buttoned up nerdy looking
guy so when you're in elementary school
one of the things you almost always do
is go around reading you know where one
person reads a paragraph and the next
person reads a paragraph when we had a
sub and it was my turn to read I would
always fake like I couldn't read very
well and I would I could read really
well but I would pretend like I couldn't
and then my friends and everyone else in
the class would laugh knowing that I was
faking it but the teacher would get mad
at them thinking they were making fun of
me and so then I have to pretend like hi
who was being made fun of we kept it
going too long and I I kept laughing too
and the teacher the substitute teacher
finally caught on to us that I was
faking with him and that I could read
well and in retrospect it was really bad
because there were kids who couldn't
read well and they probably felt shitty
so my brother who is about two grades
older than me gave me a fart machine it
was about this big with a remote control
and in our classrooms for some reason
there was a bathroom at the back of
class so on a normal day you had here a
few things coming from the bathroom but
I took the fart machine in because we
knew we were gonna have a substitute
teacher that day and I went into the
bathroom and just let off a few ribs she
was older
definitely grandma level age yeah I
think she didn't realize she was coming
in the middle school that day I think
she probably was expecting like an
elementary class and she was in for a
rude awakening I did it probably about
three
the fart noises they were varied fart
noises the first two were pretty mild
but then there was one that was it was
just a such an unbelievable fart it just
kind of went on for a while my
classmates told me out when I walked out
everybody just turned around and started
laughing at me and so the teacher asked
if I made any noises while I was in
there and I tried to say that it was
Mexican from the night before but she
saw the bulge in my pocket so after I
presented it she made me push the button
in front of class and of course another
fart came out and the whole class
laughed
she took the fart machine away and I had
my mom come in and get it so that was
kind of I know when my mom has a great
sense of humor anyway so she kind of
loved it and I'm pretty sure she took
the fart machine into work and use it
herself
now that I'm an adult I have friends
that are school teachers and I know how
hard it is so I would say give yourself
a break don't be I'm not gonna curse but
a little brat don't be a brat they're
just there to take over for your
original teacher mr. substitute teacher
I don't really remember your name but
I'm sorry I definitely felt bad about
what I did I'm really sorry I'm sorry I
apologize I did lie I did not in fact
have Mexican food the night before
[Music]